when I realized that losing your temper
was a sign of weakness as soon as I
resist as I made that connection I said
to myself this is weak I'm going to try
not to do it anymore and what's weird is
when you're a kid I don't know if you
remember this but I was a kid and you D
someone get angry and it made you afraid
and so for a while I saw it as like a
power you know it's kind of a way to
achieve power that you can lose your
temper and then all of a sudden you have
this extra strength and so when you're a
little kid and when I say a little kid I
mean when I was 13 14 years old I
thought hey if I go if I could get that
rage going and people are scared like I
used to feel that's a positive thing and
then like I said as I got older now you
you know now you're talking 16 15 16 17
I realized hey this isn't this isn't
cool
this isn't strength it's actually
weakness and when I realized it was
weakness and I didn't realize that
overnight but I started getting the idea
that that was weakness and now when you
see someone that is in control and even
when bad things are happening to look
you know they're standing stoic we said
okay let me take another look at that
and I'll get it done you mean they're
just okay then you realize okay this
guy's really unflappable which is a lot
more impressive so again you got to be
able to detach from this and you know I
like to take pride in the fact that I'm
going to keep my cool no matter what
happens and definitely once I was in
that once you're in the SEAL Teams you
definitely want to be that guy that's
keeping you're keeping a cool no matter
what's happening whether it's people are
doing the wrong thing or you just want
to be the guy that's hey okay come back
over here we need to redo this you just
want to be that guy that's way more
impressive than the guy that says ok
probably British don't be that person so
and I've talked about this before one of
the pre-event indicators that show you
or reveal to you that your temper is
about to be lost
what are they is it
you point your fist just right is it you
raise your voice and you start doing
doing that stuff just drop the heavy
breathing do you flip it you flare your
nostrils right because that's an animal
thing where you're going to take in more
oxygen so you open up the nostrils
you're about to get after it do you you
know use your gives your your head you
know shaking or what everything's just
like these things what is it what
indicators do you have when you know
that you're starting to feel that and as
soon as you feel that you detach you go
oh that's what that is that's an
indicator and it's a weakness mm-hmm and
I don't like weakness so I'm not going
to allow it and then you take a breath I
like to say it you know what here's a
good one you want it you want to get
through that that moment nod your head
slowly in the affirmative right so so
when someone's telling me something
that's making me mad I'll just slowly
nod my head like I understand this is
the way things are I accept this and
this is I'm calculating what my next
move is efficiently uh if anything or
whatever you know guys will come to ten
you know you tell your little kids that
tell your little kids when they start
losing their temper you know you need to
count to ten down to ten count to one
hundred counter thousand or whatever it
is you got to do and get control because
like I said if you're losing control
it's not strength to eat this